guys we got the dates for 2023 locked
maybe a couple more added Salt Lake City
I'll be headed your way October 27th and
28th bavia Illinois November 10th and
11th and closing out the year at Cobbs
in San Francisco California December 8th
and 9th get all tickets at
ryanr I'm excited to announce that my
special Lefty son is now available as an
audio album go check it out everywhere
you get
music I'm very excited to announce that
the Honeydew video is now available on
Spotify it doesn't change anything for
you at all it's just an additional place
to watch the Honeydew go check out the
Honeydew audio and video now available
on Spotify the Honeydew with ran
[Music]
sickler welcome back to the Honeydew
y'all we are over here doing it in the
night pant Studios I'm Ryan sichler Ryan
sickler
docomo media I'm going to start this
episode like I start every episode by
saying thank you thank you for
supporting this show thank you for
watching
subscribing thank you for supporting my
special if you haven't seen it go over
to my YouTube check that out now um come
out see me on tour listen wait I want to
say this if you gotta have more of this
show then I'm telling you you got to
check out the patreon it's five bucks a
month that's it there's no tears no none
of that it's five bucks and it's the
Honeydew with y'all and y'all have the
wildest [__] stories all right I
can't tell you how many people we just
talked to another person that died
another person that died and came back
I've talked to somebody died in in every
city on this tour so far every city
somebody has died and come back all
right go check out the Honeydew with Y
all go subscribe to the crab Feast it's
a great storytelling podcast and come
see me on tour if you're around when I'm
in your town all right what do we got
November 10th and 11th bavia Illinois
December 8th and 9th San Francisco
California that's closing out the year
and that's what we're doing over here
now you guys know what it is we're
highlighting the low lights and I always
say these are the stories behind the
storytellers very excited to have this
guest on today ladies and Gentlemen
please welcome country Wayne welcome to
the
Honeydew hey how you doing my man dude
I'm very excited to have you here thanks
thanks I am I was saying outside to you
before I I want to give her credit J
hilarious is a I'm Baltimore she's a
Baltimore girl I follow her and so
really liked her and I discovered you
through her and I was like this dude's
funny as [__] and you're clean mhm
another thing and yeah and until today
when you came here I didn't know you did
stand up CU you didn't tell anybody you
did stand up or show anybody did stand
up and then you punch him in the mouth
with the number one Netflix special yeah
man I I my fans knew but I always the
ones who knew knew the ones who didn't
didn't but you now they do yeah they hey
they know now they do they know now so
please promote plug everything and
anything you like tours your special
whatever you got uh hey man just country
Wayne you know say just Google country
Wayne and everything up there k u n t r
y Wayne well I was saying to you too
like I became a fan through that and
then I saw you pop up on Bert's podcast
I was like oh [__] yeah he's doing
podcast I want to get him on so thank
you for doing this um cuz you know we
look you up we research a little bit I
want to get into this but I want to do
some background first but you had your
first kid at 17 you have 10 children yep
10 how old are you a 35 all right yeah
all right I didn't have my first and
only until I was 40 okay wow
congratulations I still got six years on
you my first well how you did that how
you pull out
man like how you pull out all years it
wasn't hard it wasn't hard oh really it
wasn't hard oh oh I'm SI of M it wasn't
difficult oh it wasn't all I can think
about is I don't want 10 kids like I
would say that to myself I don't we
don't need 10 kids yeah all right I I
deal with them girl from that country
got that good though all right so let's
talk a little bit about where you're
from and your upbringing and then we'll
get to 17 cuz also you don't have much
that's you're already a dad at 17 you're
not getting a lot of that that that
college year stuff and that that 20-some
[__] off and playing around either
because you have I don't know how many
we'll get to it I don't know how many
kids you have by the time you're 22 or
23 we'll see no by the U but where are
you from originally I'm from a small
town called Millan Georgia Millan y
Millan Georgia about 3,000 people all
right and then uh how were your parents
together when you nah n my parents was
definitely uh weren't together come from
poverty all that so they weren't married
but were they dating or were they just
like you man you ain't poverty none you
ain't doing nothing just SC we all in
survival mode so when you married you're
not even married for real you just
trying to get it and uh I got it so you
know I couldn't I couldn't really I was
never going to be able to play around in
college and stuff anyway cuz my parents
had played around enough so I was
picking up debt for they're playing
around so what's life like growing up do
you have brothers and sisters are you an
only child uh on my mom's side I had two
sisters so it's two sisters in me I was
the youngest I'm my dad's side I got
seven siblings but I'm the oldest okay
yeah so now did how many at a time were
were you living together like your
sisters and you my sisters me and my
sisters and my mom okay and you were the
youngest yep the youngest so you're
bring you're being brought up on that
side by all ladies all ladies okay women
okay so you feel like that helped you
understand women or do you feel like it
did not help you understand it help me
it definitely made me understand it
that's why the name of my special is a
woman's prayer cuz I understood the
powerful the power in a woman's prayer
man what a woman think of you and a
woman connection to the Earth and all
that yeah yeah that is powerful it's
powerful women powerful man okay so
you're raised by your sisters and your
mom and how often is your dad around he
around every once in a while small town
so he didn't like leave leave but you
see he'd be around yeah I he be around
he didn't move out of state uh n not not
then he did later on mhm yeah how many
kids did he end up having he end up
having eight eight how many kids your
mom end up having three and you had 10
10 there's 21 kids involved in these
three people I had seven kids by the
time I was 22 no you did not yes I did
too you
had yeah you had seven kids by the time
you were 22 I had seven kids man if you
started at age three at would average
every three years you got that's insane
get seven kids how many different women
five five yep really six but me and one
of them I got custody of my daughter so
it's listen I don't know why I'm saying
this to you but when you really well
also you were young too so your sperm is
pow but the older you get it's not as
easy I hope not it's not
and it ain't don't worry it slows down a
little bit you know that for sure yeah
for for sure it's not as easy it took me
three tries thank and we were trying we
were actually attempting and you know we
weren't just [__] and having fun and
any of that uh I'm not saying that you
were yeah I'm not also not saying you
were trying to have seven kids by the
time you were 22 years old either I
definitely wasn't trying but you're how
old now 35 35 so would you say it's fair
to say that from 22 to 35 three kids you
slowed down oh 22 22 22 to 35 I've been
I've been I had more women probably
between the age of 14 and 22 than I had
between 22 and 35 how many women would
you say you dated not even slept with
just datting yeah what you mean like I
don't when on it's about three only
three three or four women that I really
dated I was going to say you're in a
small town so it can't it's not like
you're in New York and there's tons of
opportunities no I Ain really really I
was with my my high school sweetheart
she me and her got three kids okay and
my ex-wife we got three so that's it so
so the rest of them was
just but were they all local girls yes
or these girls on the no girls on the
road no these ladies all know each other
too yeah we listen did they before yeah
we I'm from that small town like that's
what I'm saying I had the women before
the fame so a lot of mistakes when women
guys get out here get excited about
women on the road and all that I had
already did that I was the famous I was
famous in high school I was famous in
kindergarten why kindergarten he said I
was famous in kindergarten I want be
honest like
my listen my baby mama was homecoming
queen my mama was Miss J Miss Jin County
my sister was homecoming queen jacs
County said yet my my son just want hon
King my family always been lit popular
in that small town okay so that small
town my mom was popular my dad was
popular so so you got a bunch of big
fish in the small town yeah bunch of big
fish in a small town so since everybody
was popular they knew you coming up
anyway cuz everybody knew Mom Dad
exactly I I rolled off they but and I
stood in it like it's like being LeBron
son but really came and Bal i i ball my
parents balling
literally balling literally all them
kids yeah all right so growing up are
you an athlete you play sports what do
you do growing up I play um basketball
baseball and football mhm what was your
favorite um favorite basketball yeah I
better at baseball though I was going to
ask what was you why why is it just too
boring baseball basketball's a lot
quicker it was hot outside man what's
that it was hot outside hot
outside you chose the AC black people
boy it gets get too hot that's funny D
all right so 17 is your high school
sweetheart then right this is your first
child what happens how do you find out
she tell you do you freak out do you how
do you react uh well her period ain't
come on and I was like oh good lord then
you know you pray oh it's late every
little spot you H is pered coming on it
didn't so then went to the doctor find
out she was pregnant I was how old was
she uh she was 18 okay I was in 11th
grade so I signed up for the military
immediately hold on there was no um talk
or anything of of aborting the baby it
was always we're going to have this baby
yeah yeah we talk her too though I mean
yeah yeah but I gave her I gave her
money but uh she ain't do it but uh she
get the money back nah
took your money and gave you a baby bro
I got to joke about on the stage I took
your abortion money and gave you a baby
I said I told my son I had a h out on
him when he was
young he don't like that joke BR like it
ain't a joke all right so now she says
I'm going to do it and how do you feel
about this are you freaking out or you
just like all right [__] not really man
not really I'm that type of person once
I do something I don't try to I'm I'm
like hey man end of the day this what it
is is I I about to force nobody to do
nothing I just was doing it I was just
leaving it as an option in case she
wanted to do that I don't want to make
her have it either you know but it's
just growing up in those environments
but we had and I went I signed up for
the military cuz my daddy said he said
man you you ain't even taking care of
yourself yet so I'm like okay but then
he said I thought you was a smart one in
front of somebody like trying to I said
okay so I signed up for the military so
they let you go to basic training on the
way to 11th grade I mean on the way to
12th grade and I supposed to go back to
AIT after 12th grade okay but I ain't go
back yeah so I ain't go a wall I I just
went B
wall okay I Ain't You by byy y'all
by what branch was it um National Guard
all right well 1 Bravo thank you for
your abbreviated service country hell H
artillery I was I made it through basic
training though I know a couple guys
that did National Guard cuz it what was
it like uh one weekend a month and then
two weeks a year or something like that
you had to give yeah but we got to go on
I supposed to go back I just went to
basic training so I did graduate basic
training but then when you didn't go
back they didn't come find you they
tried to but I told him I told him I had
Skol
Elis the first thing I thinking is I
would have been like look I'm a teenage
father you went with
scol and I'm flat
footed [__] yeah you you don't want me
on the front lines that's what I told
I'm flat footed so if you want somebody
out there walking like this back Cricket
feet flat looking like a duck they not
going to be scared of
us all
right so now you're out of the military
M and what happens next man I went to
the streets started hustling man I need
I need some money okay is your baby born
at this point yet yeah I had him he was
born okay so your first child son okay
yep first month of 12th grade yep are
you back in school yeah I'm back in
school I'm back what it feel like to be
a dad in class do you feel like like man
I feel like you feel older than the
teacher I feel like I feel I feel like
me and the teacher can hear these kids
I'm in here with these kids cuz my life
was real I had to buy milk Pampers just
this little baby looking at me that I
love so much now seeing it looking in my
eyes and I'm like hey man it's my son
and I got to stand in it Point Blank
period so you go to the streets and
start doing what what are you selling
I'm selling cocaine Coke mhm and you do
you ever get robbed do you ever have any
problems out there doing that people
didn't pay me sometimes but I ain't
really have too many problems nah and
what's considered a good day for you on
the street well at that time I was small
town hustling but later on I got bigger
so you started in your small town small
town so then how' you get bigger just my
reputation is get more money um you get
you get a connection so I could buy more
dope for a cheaper
price and you're using that dope money
to feed your baby baby and yeah all
right feed my baby in my dream just late
on down the road okay baby and dream by
the time I was 22 I was really pushing
towards the dream all right but I did
have before I did have a job uh when I
first started hustling right after the
school I got caught fast I got a felony
I got 10 years probation how' they catch
you they really didn't catch me I ran I
got away but I threw the drugs early and
then they sent the dog to go look the
dog couldn't find it either but the dog
had to take a pee and and lift his right
leg up and peed right there yeah and he
peed and sat down and was like it's
right here it's right it's right here
guess what I say God dog
it I been dog on I know where they
saying come from
[Laughter]
now me do God is
right all right so you get pinched and
you get out quick on that though I got
10 they let me out but I had to go to
court I a know getting 10 years felling
in probation damn mhm so now you got a
felony can't vote can't carry a gun
can't do any of that [__] yeah and I
ain't I ain't do none of that anyway so
okay 17 kid number one how old are you
when Child Number Two happens Child
Number Two uh 18 so no 19 I had just
turned 19 same girlfriend same girl so
you have your first three with her yeah
first no I had another one so two of
them born at the same
time like with two weeks apart same
Hospital
you had two kids born two weeks apart in
the same hospital when a nurse see me
come in the second week just they should
just give you a wing down there hey when
a nurse see me come in the second week
she was like Mr Co did you leave
anything yeah I know I dropped something
else
off so I'm looking in the glass again
same
situation same doctors oh no that is
terrible everybody the same but the mom
huh mhm and they and the baby and the
baby that's hilarious yeah and they um
they best friends like those two they
real close did they know each other so
wait one and two are with high school
sweetheart mhm how old are you when
number three happen oh [__] you're
you're you're the same week same so the
other one came okay so now you got three
but the one I had the third one with my
baby mom but I had dealt with another
girl so she eased in and stopped at
number three spot yeah and four his
number four back with childh okay one
two then I had I had another
one I had another one uh the third oh
three was actually somebody else
somebody else went to this girl house
one night man and that was it one time
and I didn't even can I ask you that be
honest with me you didn't even finish I
thought I
did but it was like you know how you
finish but it be
like but I fin I but then the baby
M have you ever truthfully be honest
with me yes I have just had sex with a
woman one time and got her pregnant and
the only time the only time let's say
that my three yeah the my three middle
Baby M each one of them got pregnant me
dealing with them that one time just a
one night stand that one that first
night all three of them all three of
them all three of them I promise you God
was like you know better so that is wild
I'm I'm I got some for you all three all
three okay so you're uh how old are you
22 and you already have seven seven mhm
how are you even doing that where do you
spend most of your time in the bedroom
most of
the in the [__] where you spend most
of your time in [__]
yeah I'm from the country we a have no
cable we a't have nothing country you
created a country what the [__] are you
talking about did I did I created I
created I
created all right hold
on I guess what I mean is are you
staying like what's base camp for you so
to speak are you staying with your high
school sweetheart you house cuz you're
you're a kid you're not are you still at
home no my baby Mama's house okay Mom
and Dad don't say you can stay here man
I was already man I was already throwing
parties making money I was I was getting
money all right so you're St staying in
her place it was my it was my outlet M
you know what I'm saying I never did
drug it sound like an inlet bro I never
a lot of leaving it in I never Dr I
never smoked I never parted for real so
women was always that's your Vice that
that was my vice M you know but these
women I cared about you
know and so now at at 22 with 7 kids mhm
are you selling more what do you do do
you get a different job like is or is
this one comedy really start to lean
into comedy no comedy didn't take out
till I like 26 27 but no that 27 I was
um I was hustling and I was doing good
in the streets but now I'm trying to
make it I'm really trying to get out I'm
trying to get me and my family out so
I'm trying to do the rap I'm trying to
be a rapper um all this doing par is I'm
hustling you know to figure things out
and what are the ages of the Kids 1
through seven at the time you're 22 22
uh you got what a 5-year-old down to one
newborn basically Jesus Christ yeah
seven children under five y sure was
that's a lot dude that's crazy that is
think of that just hear that
yeah seven whole children under the age
of five oh my God that's a class bro
that is a class that people will be paid
well to take care of how did that make
it I don't know dude wow I don't how did
you that's what I'm saying how are you
seeing how are you seeing everybody and
is everybody in close proximity a to
drive small time yeah small time man and
to this day man and my kids man we it's
it's love we all we all lit and all this
cuz I always wanted the big family
anyway you know uh I could have had
about one woman but that wasn't my life
and I don't regret it because the way it
played out that played out for me now my
son shouldn't do that but uh the
envirment I was in it was just man being
in a relationship and thinking about
marriage and all that man we trying to
surv in survival mode you can't think
about none of that it you cannot I don't
care you cannot be in love in Survival
Mode you trying to get out that's well
said yeah that is well said that's not
even you right now you just faking you
coping with each other y'all each other
cop coping mechanism I was woke I was
like man we can't be if a bill come it
could throw up our whole lovely day yeah
if you go on a date and you happy and in
love you and the kids but you got this
somebody get sick and you can't afford
to p man you ain't you no so I was
focused on getting out getting that
money and what are your parents saying I
mean you just made them grandparents
five times over by the time you're 22
nobody ain't take nobody ain't have to
take stand up for me I did they did they
help you did they want to help I
wouldn't let nobody help I paid
everybody babysit my kids I was I was
always that type of person I don't want
no favors cuz I ain't going to give you
no favor back when it's time when I'm up
so uh at that point I was just I was
just man I knew I was going to be
successful so I was just like making it
work where I was at I got a job for two
years doing what I worked at a power
plant and um and and I I tried to make
it work but at child support went up I
like this cheick ain't enough so I got
back in the
streets now from 20 go ahead sorry from
from 20 from 19 for 20 to 22 I had a job
okay now 22 to 35 which you are now you
have three more kids mhm how how far
apart does that happened you have a
newborn right now I got a Oney old you
got a Oney old sixy old and a niney old
Jesus two kids under six is a lot mhm so
you never felt like man I'm out of the
woods now I'm not going to go back and
do that again you just were like I'm
going to just keep doing what I do and
my ex wife on two of them was with my ex
wife so I had one since then my exwife
was the last two before the last one now
everyone you said gets along yeah we
yeah we was just up here celebrating in
my new my house in Baer all my my baby
mama was up here all the kids stay with
each other they go to they all got rooms
at my house it's it's a big Village yeah
do they and do all the kids get along
too man that's that is awesome oh yeah
it's beautiful that is awesome and
you're young enough now too honestly to
enjoy it you're not 70 or 80 with all
this going on like like I'm going to be
yeah it's fun cuz my son I play
basketball with him they play bar one of
them just went out to college to play
basketball they come home they um they
make money with me online with one of
them I guess is 18 then right 17 and
35 full man Gru last year damn my kids
older and they help they keep me up on
what's it worked out for me I want to
now they shouldn't do what I did because
their envirment different so it wasn't
right to do what I did but it's my wrong
it ain't nobody else wrong it ain't you
know it just like man when people be
that's why I make jokes about it and
talk about on stage because I'm like bro
nobody can't when took somebody in them
environments and understand poverty man
you can't man
n so what's your relationship with your
parents like who are you closest to your
mom or your dad my mom passed when I was
11 11 oh you were young yeah I was young
oh you didn't even have her after so you
didn't get her long no I had to grow up
fast what was do you remember what that
was like oh yeah I mean you're little
but it was like you alone already you
when that Mama gone I'm talking about
she was my momma I'm talking about lay
up on the her she feels warm you know
she's cooking so when you lose that the
everything else you be like so what you
just like I lost that at a young age so
that was the part of me that was like um
I had to learn how to nurture myself so
how did you do that um I had to start
being detail like a woman things that my
mama would do I had to learn how to
clean up and um and and just be
nurturing pay attention to myself like
like a woman you know I really had to be
detailed a lot because that part of me
was gone so somebody got their mom out
there man listen here I don't care what
you say if you got a mama or you got a
wife in your life that's who keeping you
detailed cuz I had to learn to be
detailed you know uh cuz and would you
would you say you pick that up from the
different ladies along the way like
little I'm more detail than them no
h hell no
man I picked that up because when that
part of you gone you got somebody got to
fulfill it and nobody don't come
instantly fulfill it you start to
learning it's like a a uh it's like a a
turtle a turtle with no shell you going
to be you going to build a shell you
going to realize what your body needs
and what I was missing was nurturing so
I'm like my mama would have did this I
can't sit around and watch myself not
have nothing to eat I got to learn how
to cook I got to learn how to dress I
got to learn how to clean that up clean
my room wash these dishes you know what
I'm saying saying so I had to learn how
to every time I pee I wipe the toilet
and I taught my sons only one of them
Listen My mama taught me that when I was
young she said every time you pee a man
PE take the tissue and wipe the toilet
cuz even though you can't see the
moisture is on there so you'll have
yellow stains on your toilet so I had to
learn how to do certain things that my
mom was gone and would have did for me
but you pick that up cuz ain't nobody
was there to save me now were your
sisters at least helping out a little
bit or were they also in their own
Survival Mode uh they had my grandma
okay but my grandma
wasn't nobody never really when it came
to me my mama was my best friend she
understood me cuz she knew country Wayne
before the world new country Wayne She
always said you going to be a big star
so it's like you had to handle me a
little different because I'm don't I'm
not folling for the BS I was a child I
can see through the once I seen my
parents take a drink I'm like oh they're
not my
leader I'm like oh my God these so I was
already woke as a child like you really
on your own even as a child your parents
are just your provide and protect an
environment you're never covered cuz
when a child can't go to a mo a parent
can't go to school with you that child
getting bullet and he can't come home
and tell parents cuz it's like you don't
know what's really going on so I had to
man I had to figure I had to figure life
out at a young age for sure now is your
dad when your mom passes he come around
a little more at all he went further
away I came home on some supposed to be
staying with him I went to my cousin's
house for the summer in Atlanta came
back he was missing I ain't seen my dad
for 3 years years yeah and he was
supposed to be you were supposed to be
living with him where'd he go he be in
town sometimes they like you know your
daddy was here and I go look man man his
name and you're what 11 or 12 yeah his
name is
skip skip town like a
[__] he lived up he lived up to
his
name he lived up to his name okay so let
me ask you this what would you say you
have how many five different women you
have kids with what would you say you
picked up differently from each one of
these ladies that you value U like what
is other than obviously they each have
given you a child of course but I mean
outside of that as a woman in your life
what do you think you've picked up from
each one of them I Pi positive attribut
positive ATT positive I don't want you
be like that made me start feel like
those women all prove to me if you got
their back unintentional if you love
them unconditionally like have their
back and provide and protect for them
without intentions of you got to give me
your body or if I do this right then
that's the only way I get rewarded I
take care of all those women I got
custody of one of my daughters two of my
daughters and the mom's not even I mean
the mom when the mom not even around one
of my children and I still give the mom
her child supp support so it's like but
they all in and
and I learned that man they were pray
for you without praying for you it's not
like this getting on their knees and but
I know they all want me to win because
if they if I win they win they win and
they truly know that so it's like they
all get the ego out of the way they that
and when a woman prayer is with you man
like I tell people a woman got two
vaginas she got the regular vagina and
that spiritual
vagina we know which one you came at all
the time I went for that spiritual
vagina I used I when I was young I used
to go for the physical vagina but man
you messing around and catch bacteria
fish
but that that's that physical vagina is
controlled by her but that spiritual
vagina is controlled by God it's her
prayer that's what real man so that's
what I learned man the women if you if
they know you got their back they could
be with somebody else another man but
whoever they feel like got them that's
and that's how businesses stay up they
feel like that's how the that's how the
um the the the welfare and food stamp
stay up because it's people praying
that the government keep getting they
cut so they could keep sending their
money back so it's like companies you
know a good company man they praying it
just keep going so I a woman prayer is
more powerful so that's what I learned
for sure and how many um boys and girls
do you have what's the split two boys
and eight girls yeah what it's it really
eight girls Yeah man so you brought all
the ladies into the world you do have a
feminine energy and these women oh my
God they all got a oh raising daughters
man I have one she's about to be nine
next month it's already it's here it's
already here get like nine when they get
five they get then when they get like
nine 10 and when they get a teenager you
don't know nothing that's what everybody
tells me you ain't gonna know nothing my
daughters just think yeah and they and
it's so bad cuz they'll say yes sir and
listen and they're not listening nothing
you going to know which child listening
you're G to be able to tell by the way I
have to ask her back like what I just
say eight eight times out of 10 she will
get it
yeah other times she like I I wasn't
listening I'm like I know you weren't
they don't
listen yep what's the difference for you
in raising boys and
girls um the difference with
boys um and girls I feel
like I feel like with the girls they
love discipline
more boys take it too personal sometimes
a woman discipline when your daughters
when you discipline your daughter she
don't like it but she love it she feel
like that's my daddy love she'll be like
she'll go tell her friend my daddy don't
play by me like he just won't let me do
nothing she kind of love that because
she recognized love more your son think
you he hey man he think you trying to
come at them and all that but that your
daughter I told my daughters I said I
know y'all love and I discipline y'all
cuz it's like if a woman put up a
picture online and her boyfriend hit up
take that down she going to be in front
of her friend he just won't let me do
nothing like he just he just love me so
much good God
like it's like a different vibe she feel
like that's my husband don't play by me
you know what I'm saying so I think the
daughters appreciate discipline more now
with your son is 18 if you guys ever had
a is he bigger than you yeah yeah my
stepson's uh he's 20 now that
motherfucker's 6'5 yeah my son said I'm
5'10 I'm little yeah he 6 three you ever
ever you ever has he ever mess with you
act like he's going to take you no but
what what they do when we play
basketball they foul me extra hard and
try to use where that come
from elbow to the neck come on and I
seen your lip ball up yeah
yeah what that brother I'm just trying
to shoot a a a jump shot a foul then
they got the ball in the head I'm like
all that take out they do it in the game
mhm so I'm going to ask you this cuz you
out you said you went to the streets you
sold dope or No Coke excuse me you sold
Coke give me
um I asked this a lot cuz I know got
we've had guests that's gone to prison
and and I asked them what they do miss
about what do you miss about it do you
feel like the hustle of that helped you
with the hustle of life with comedy with
uh tell me for sure do you think that
taught you more than school yeah the
hustling gang taught me business I
understand if you ain't got no money in
it you going to get pimp so I it's like
and you also were smart you never used
your product that's the biggest problem
most of the people never could get high
for your own Supply right that's the
number one rule that's the number one
rule so it definitely helped me because
I understood ownership through that so
I'm not scared to put up my own money on
my businesses and projects I do I
understand that so I came in this game
as a as a ex dope boy as we call it in
the hood uh I understand the business is
a little different I understand you
can't get no you got to put some money
up in this world if you if you go if you
build a business and ain't put too much
time and too much money in it it's going
to get you in the end agreed it need
your time your attention and your money
so it taught me a lot about flipping and
and and just how it taught me how to
Market because to be a drug dealer you
got to be a great marketer because how
what are you do what are you doing
here's what I because I know a lot of
guys do the pizza guide delivery what
what are you doing cuz it's a small town
also so that means the cops probably
know who everybody is as well so how are
you getting around that because it was
just like I sold weight so what I would
do you didn't do little bags you no I
did at first that's how I got caught so
what I started doing I sold weight and
so if I buy half a brick if I buy a
brick it was 36 oun I take that one
brick put some cut on it and turn it
into two and a half brick what are you
cutting it with um manat who who's doing
that you me you're actually doing it my
process but it was um but I did that it
was it wasn't nothing that the menot was
a neutralizer a sweetener so it didn't
do nothing to you so my drugs was
actually weak you couldn't you my unle
say he snorted some mine and went and
took a p test the next day with in a
probation officer and he was
F your Coke doesn't even show up on man
I cut my drill so
bad I put it in the blend I love I love
that he did cook your Coke anyway
knowing he was doing a drug test the
next yeah he was SC he knew he thought
he was going to go to jail he said and
the lady say everything's fine he said
man you're good like I he said my nephew
ain't nothing they my nephew stash ain't
[__] nothing selling
weight I sold weight oh godamn and it
helped me to this day cuz that's
probably why he hit my stand
up because in a do drug business you got
to Market without marking it so how are
you doing that tell me how you're
getting around town doing that word am M
that's it word them out all people who
knew what I was doing were people who
knew what I was doing okay people she
not going to clubs or bars or letting it
be known or anything like that it's a
matter of time it's just like agree it's
just like you say when you ask me about
my stand up I didn't have the answer
earlier but now that's why I hit my
stand up I'm like if they ain't paying
for it I'm not going to keep using my
stand up to advertise you to come see CU
then I got to come up with new jokes so
I give you this to advertise it I'm
funny skits but I H my stand up people
didn't know I did stand up to the
Netflix special for real I people new
was my fans but now the world got to see
because that's how I was moving in The
Dope Game you everything is money you
got to monetize everything you do so
ain't nothing that's why I love the
parallels that's also why I love the
wire they they parallel the cops and the
and the and the drug uh side and how
like the lower ranks come up but that's
what I'm saying that mindset of man you
did it right yeah but I could but to
mean to say kids to kids out there do
not sell drugs do not it's not worth it
not these days you will die these days
you really can't do drugs these days
just just don't do drugs don't do drugs
I promise you cuz if you do drugs you're
going to get tooken advantage of in
business I don't care what nobody say if
you do drugs in life you're going to get
just be know that it's going to be
somewhere in life you getting taken
advantage of and because you're not woke
on every situation so I understood that
cuz my momma my daddy all them did drugs
so smart man learn from his own mistakes
a wise men learn out the mistakes of
others so I just seen the game what do
you learn from how many years did you do
it um 201 2016 oh I did it for you did
it for a minute what do you learn the
most dealing cocaine to people what do
those people like you seeing them every
are they businessmen all you know what
I'm saying you seeing all what customers
like customers like customer service I
was a
Chick-fil-A I'll wear out in front of
you I'm not cheating you with the gr you
bu point you give my pleasure every time
hey man if you if you want 56 G I might
56.5 you know what I mean I wear it out
in front of you so they people
love the feeling of something so that's
why so you're letting them come right
into you see you weigh and over it's not
already meet them somewhere and yeah
it's like you know when I meet them it's
just a customer service you want me to
bring it to you I bring it to you you
want to come get it come get it and
other than the one time you got caught
the on smaller amounts you never got
pinched on the bigger stuff no on when
the fed well when I don't want to talk
about that
but they got my daddy they get me we end
up selling drugs together that's they
got the right
guy to make a long story short me my dad
in selling drawers together no from 2010
to
2016 can we talk about it yeah I talk
about my stand up all right good cuz you
don't have a close relationship with the
man to begin with so how does it come
back first of all to together just to be
talking and communicating and then
evolve into business together he got out
of um when I was in 11th grade my daddy
came back around for real for real no
ninth grade he came back around but by
the time I was in 11th grade we was back
close again okay so we back close 11
12th grade and what was he in prison for
uh he sold drug my whole family sold
drug so everybody he getting out and
he's just going right back to everybody
my whole family okay whole family sold
drugs did drugs that's it and U he went
to prison when I was in 12th grade oh he
went back yeah he went pris when I was
12th grade for how long he did four
years the first time and how long the
second time five four or five damn all
for that drills the first time then uh
he got out 200 N and me he'll started
selling drills 2010 how did that come
about whose idea man it was it was
really his kind of because what happened
was you're already doing it by yourself
no I'm not selling drugs at this I'm
working this job oh [__] I'm working
this job but man we having fun every day
but one day you know how you you know
how you short on money working you got a
cheick coming but you need some money to
get you through the week I said Daddy
you got $40 I just need $40 to help me
with lunch um all week he said thanks
son I was about to ask you for 40 we
looked at each
other man I said we got to do something
else man so I went to the bank I got a
bank loan I I Ed my car title um got got
me a bank loan for
$55,000 and uh
I left the money with him and then when
I I went to work that week came back he
don't went and holler at the plug in
Florida and I'm bought back of 4 and a
half ounces of cocaine is that worth
five
grand no it was worth three okay it was
like 3500 cuz I had spent some of the
money get my R I had spent some of that
fire get my radiator fixed okay my
radiator and stuff fixed on my car some
new tires on the box Chevy I had I Ain
want to tell y'all that CU I Ain know
much St you
had this this honey dude not me dude so
I a want to I a't want to dry your
listeners ears out we're good we got
time I skipped I skipped parts of story
on we got time we don't have to edit
yeah so I um all right so you he goes
and gets this brick or fourway 4 and a
half ounces fourway and and it's just
there and then he tells you this is what
we we should do he was like son
yo and at the time he already had some
connections I'm guessing cuz he was
already dealing no he had a con Florida
man they s bad though we got rid of it
though but it was bad and then after I
made a money back how do you know it was
bad cuz you don't do it cuz when people
coming back and telling you yeah it was
weak people was like it was weak you
know what I mean and you can smell it I
smell it but my dad did it you never did
it on your gums or my dad was I've never
done cocain I'm scared of death my dad
done cocaine he used to test all the
drugs and one and one night he was the
tester he tested some one night man he
snorted about seven grams cuz he's like
man dang this ain't nothing
qu he said they G sld some fake
drugs damn he snorted about a quar oce
he said man first thing in the morning
I'mma call him man cuz the plug W answer
the phone call him it about 1:00 in the
morning so the conect connect going
answering the phone so he say in the
morning I'm calling him I'm taking his
back son he said man I'm sorry he say
son I'm sorry man they got us man he
snorted like seven G so I live up the
house about 4:00 in the morning I get a
call phone ring it's my daddy I say
what's up P he
s ain't nothing wrong with that
Dr it just took a minute to get
you oh call you when my mouth a open he
said it's good son it good he said said
I call you back on M
Hospital hosital bro he like to die he
said that it snuck up on them it was it
was that
cocaine it didn't hit you right there
[__] it was that cocaine man my dad
mouth was BW to girl I say man jaw tee
down and [__] just snow the
ground and we just wait and see before
we got the blood again it's always do it
and wait an hour it's always
whatever you think you should do you do
half supposed to die he was supposed to
die man I went to him his ey I was SE
him day his eyes was
swo this man look like he had e some
allergic Seafood this brother was I say
Daddy man you supposed to die he said I
know son he said his heart was beat so
fast one time he was scared to get up he
said he knew if he if he would have got
up he would have died he said his heart
was I feel like I'm going to
die oh God damn dude I remember him
saying saying he felt like he had two
hearts he said they was
like he said it was be
like yeah man yeah he was a tester
man all right here's a question I have
for you uh anybody ever surprise you you
ever get a pastor or a teacher or
someone you you know what I mean
somebody maybe you knew for elementary
school teacher as a customer I mean heck
yeah
y people surpris me like like who who
would come up and you be like no way
this guy wants coat or this lady wants
coat it's this lady who I really respect
man and I don't lose respect but she he
wasn't even Coke she had to deal with
somebody I know she was on crack I like
God dog she holding up so well oh really
yeah and you couldn't see it on her so
now when everybody ask me for money in
my family and they be needing money too
much I be like are you on crack I always
ask that because of her cuz she you
couldn't see it on her
so I always learned that um man just cuz
you don't see it on people if you got
money that's why a lot of people who in
the like in the industry entertainers
music or
whatever they can't you'll never be able
to tell cuz money can cover it up for a
minute if you if you could put some
Gucci on some crackhead
shoulders hey you can't tell it just
look like they just vibing you know but
yo so it was heard and then after that I
was just like this what it is this is
streets so you and your dad do this for
six years yeah and why do you end up
stopping I went
viral you were so you were doing all
this country waying your sketches and
stuff while you're dealing coke with
your dad I'm two million followers
strong still selling drugs no popular
for real country Wayne you got a you got
a family business going on with your dad
I can't I can't let it go right now cuz
it's you know I'm famous but I ain't
getting no show money yet so at 2
million followers you're still selling
drugs mhm with your dad and then what
happens what what what puts you to the
point where you're like all right I'm I
I'm done I don't need to ever again okay
well first of all he got and how does
your business partner feel about you
leaving the business oh my God my daddy
was trying to hold me in the streets bro
he did not want me to leave cuz he like
he didn't want me to leave man he was
like cashow he want me to leave and um
he pretended like he wanted me to go but
you you you just see the signs like BR
we TR we trying to get but you buying a
car like you know so but he messed
around and uh got caught one night oh he
did and the police beat him but he uh he
had altercation with the police and they
had to take him to the hospital and they
forgot to arrest him so when he got to
the hospital uh what do you mean they
forgot because he they just [__] him
up and no they they didn't do the oh
they didn't cuff him no they cuffed them
and everything but they Ain do the um
the process whatever they call I forgot
the name of it but um read them is
Miranda Right and fingerprint them and
alling they had him at the table but
then he was about to faint and they was
like WR he said so they like they take
it to the hospital so they they never
finished that part so when he got to the
hospital so that's a technicality where
technicality right but when he got to
the hospital the police was going to sit
there with him but the doctor said you
can't sit here because he's not arrested
so they said we'll come back and get him
in the morning so man I called him and
checked on him I say it's all right Pops
I'm going be all right out here man I'm
going do this I'mma um do this music
thing I'mma man and something my spirit
told me to call him back I said so when
the police at they still outside said no
they going to come back and pick me up
in the morning because they say uh the
doctor say I wasn't arrested man do you
know I told my daddy leave that hospital
right now this
2014 I said leave that hospital he said
what I said man get out of there you and
your girlfriend and he he basically ran
from the hospital and they was looking
for him for two years so two years yep
the reason why we quit because when I
finally went vir and start doing shows I
quit and the next day after I quit the
feds came looking for him so it was like
they was on us the whole time you know
kind of but yeah that was it was a crazy
situation a lot of crazy things happened
but that's how we end up ending um I
quit fed came to get him cuz he was
keeping going cuz they was looking for
him for two years anyway and then after
that man I was cring Wayne to the world
funny guy so how many followers and like
what level of Fame do you hit where you
finally walk away from the I was getting
show money people started want to boot
me for 5,000 here 4,000 here so I was
like and you were like I'm done with
this [__] I'm making I'm making 20 2030
Grand a month without drugs it's it I'm
gone yeah yeah without drugs that's
right yeah without
hustling so going back to growing up
earlier before we uh one of your friends
out there said you were a bad kid like
what tell me about you growing up as a
kid little little little country Wayne
everything funny I'm a I'm a Pity like I
just like to laugh so that's what he
mean by that like you like play
practical jokes on people [__] I play
like that I it's just like it could be a
real serious
moment I'm still going to
laugh like I'm I'm a laugher I like the
joy like it ain't nothing that serious
inappropriate times and [__] is the best
of best Church you ain't supposed to
laugh and see somebody laughing next to
you just shaking and you trying to hold
it I'm trying to hold it man when people
go to Cryme about stuff I'm like come on
man don't don't make that
face oh my God you know I can't help it
I like to laugh that's what it mean by
that I laugh at a lot of stuff so talk
to me about having 10 kids man
because you got basically you said one I
mean that's a newborn basically yeah all
the way up to a grown man mhm how do you
balance that man you know um cuz I know
every baby's different every this one
might like to be swaddled this one might
like to be held this one might how do
you and you've got eight ladies yep you
kind of you just do what they like
whatever they want whatever you feel
like they need at the moment you try
your best to just do it you know what
I'm saying that's what I do for sure you
like being a dad oh yeah I love it man
it's the it's the it's the most
fulfilling thing I got going on I agree
like that's nice to hear you say too
because you have a lot going on in your
life you just you just dropped a Netflix
special at number one you got everything
going on online you got a tour going all
that [__] and here you are sitting here
saying that the the best thing you do is
a dad I love it that's it man my most
exciting thing this year and thank God I
got number one on Netflix I'm ready for
my son Varsity games yeah I take off I
take off um I told my agency you know
saying I'm taking off November through
February I'm not going back on tour to
March cuz for his
basketball he's excited it's his first
year being able to uh play Varsity cuz
he couldn't play cuz he transferred from
a pop private school last year so it was
a little M up but he's on the varsity
team and he he's good and me and my
family love to go see that so it's like
the Netflix special going number one I
was grateful the most thing I was
grateful for was my kids seeing that
because I'm so my brand is positive but
they listen to all the negative stuff
negative music cuz you as a parent you
got to compete with the world so I'm
like I'm showing them that you could be
positive cool cuz my brain is Jesus is
popping and everybody know that Wayne's
positive I don't curse him a comedy or
whatever so it's about them kids it's
like when you
get and life is really even when you get
rich it's like the way tax is set up you
got to give it away anyway so you know
it's just like that's what it's about
that why I watch the Dion Sanders I'm
like people don't know I know that Joy
he feeling there's no amount of money a
person can pay to feel that he's out
there coaching his son dude I love I got
my Colorado hoodie when I was in the
hospital in January I was ready to go
I'm so excited for what they're going to
do how old is your daughter she'll be
nine next month yeah man when you see
you know you know how you know I'm
pretty sure you don't have no moments
where you looking
at this what really matter dude I do it
every weekend I go to her soccer game so
you know what I'm saying and I stand
behind the goal and I see her in the net
and I just look and I'm like I don't
give a [__] about when she stop that
ball that feeling runs out there not
scared and Dives on it yeah that's and
when she's excited when when you see her
really excited about her work so that
thing there man you know what else I
love too is like sometimes I'll I'll
I'll I'll know I'm going to one of her
events but I don't tell her and then
when I show up that excitement you see
in a kid it's like man somebody's here
I'm I'm being repped right now I'm being
loved and man just to see and then she's
got this energy and I see her start
acting differently with their friends I
[__] love being able to do that
that's real man yeah that's real and um
and think me not having my mom at a age
I think I needed that to be honest now
looking back at me having all them kids
I'm like man I needed my kids are they
because you can't man you can't replace
that Joy you don't get it you know it's
already gone with your other son he's
he's a man now yeah different Joys
different things will come you'll be a
grandfather hopefully not too soon oh no
I'm going be a dead be
granddaddy you should be dude [__]
have put your I'm a good daddy but I
promise you I'm going to be the worst
granddaddy in
history I'm not keeping no kid I don't
care not a night no going to the story
going out taking with you I will call
the people and tell them you left a
child I hear abandoned I'm going to be a
dead I tell my kids boy don't don't
don't do it cuz I'm not keeping them
kids man you could be a a legit
grandfather under 40 yeah easy what that
well [__] your pro your dad was he how
old was your dad when you made him a
grandfather he was 40 40 yeah yeah a
young grandfather right they better U so
let me ask you this the the two
daughters you have uh complete custody
of um and you're still good with their
mom and everything yeah so what is it do
it's so different you got how do you
make time for all these kids how do you
make time to see them talk to them do
you FaceTime a lot cuz think about
coming up there wasn't that opportunity
either mhm you know what I mean you just
if somebody didn't have a phone on the
wall and you weren't there at the same
time you weren't talking to them so how
how are you are you able to FaceTime and
keep in touch FaceTime and they um eight
of my kids stay right around me in my
house in Atlanta my son stay with me
24/7 and U the rest of them their mom
stay right around the corner so they all
come there everybody's close everybody
close hell yeah I love and then when
they spending time with each other they
feel like they spending time with me cuz
the other baby M might take them go out
of town with them and you know oh they
will they was all just up here like um
how many of my kids was here one two
four of my kids was up here with um we
had a Netflix celebration yesterday um
they was up here they're going to go
back the other my my other baby mama
Mama's keeping them while the other baby
mama go on her vacation trip so I'm F to
have eight of eight of my kids to my
house they all got rooms so it's just
like it's a family man we all a family
all my whole family
uh that's why my success man I take care
of my whole family for real like
everybody get a chick every month how's
that feel for you it feels good man does
does it feels good because I like that
you're not just hoarding it and being
like [__] all y'all this is my [__] I
did this you got to give away that money
because uh uh uh they say you go money
buying things but God say if you help
people I got you it comes back I tell
everybody all the time young 20
something I I would have told
50-year-old me [__] you that that's a
$20,000 a lot of money these
[__] took from me and that's
family I want that [__] money and for
years I would think about that and then
later in life I realized this don't
worry this shit's coming back it's
coming back it's going to come when you
really need it you didn't need it that
moment you would have [__] [__] it
off too on some stupid ass Mustang or
some dumb [__] you know something
you really don't even have so I feel you
on that it does feel good to provide mhm
yeah I get I I get a joy out of that too
like I'll pay for that I got that like I
sent my daughter and her mother I don't
know it was a couple months ago I was on
the road and I was like why don't you
all do a a mom daughter night and I told
my daughter like go see Little Mermaid
again and I paid for them to go watch
you know get to popcorn do whatever go
hang out with Mom yeah I don't know
feels good if it's good it ain't a
[__] mansion in belir with everybody
but I tell you what it's
popcorn man get the medium size you know
yeah yeah so that's what it is man
yeah all right so look I told you
outside we talked this is your first
time here um I want to hear ADV because
this is a very it's a just so for me I I
understand where you're coming from my
mom left our family early on and my dad
died when I was 16 so from then on I
have no parents and I feel you like I
mean [__] I learned how to tie a tie on
YouTube you know what I mean like I wish
I had YouTube when I was 16 and 198
[__] n figuring this [__] out on
myself so your story of coming up that
way figuring it out yourself really
resonates um you're a dad at 17 and I
ask everyone their first time hear
advice that you would give to your
16-year-old self I'm curious after just
what we've talked about today looking
back what advice would you give 16y Old
Country
Wayne lead with love every time not with
lust that's a
great that's great advice for
16-year-old you
dude I like that instead of like pull
out you know like make sure
there's that connection is it might be
bigger than lust don't don't eliminate
lust and see what they and see what that
moment really is yeah cuz lust can turn
into a whole person yeah lust turn into
a whole
person with hands that do
this yeah and a mouth that needs to eat
[__] man I'm telling you
dude country Wayne thank you very much
for coming on it's been I it's one of
the hardest times I've laughed in a
minute I needed one of these sometimes
these get heavy as [__] and I appreciate
you bringing uh uh lightness to this so
again please plug everything your
special your all of it yeah man country
Wayne on Netflix special out a woman's
prayer just type in country Wayne with a
K and just follow the journey man and uh
peace and love to everybody all love
that's awesome thank you as always Ryan
sickler on all social media ransler
docomo tour tickets are on my website
we'll talk to youall next
[Music]
[Applause]
week